[Music]
that is Carrie Underwood crunch tears of
glitter to announce the name of her new
single cry pretty now Carrie has been
slowly easing her way back into the
spotlight after that devastating fall
five months ago which required around 40
to 50 stitches on her face well now in a
letter to fans Carrie is revealing how
she's healing the singer says quote
physically I'm doing pretty darn good
these days my wrist is almost back to
normal about 90 percent there and my
face has been healing pretty nicely as
well
carrie has shared a few new photos since
the accident back in the studio and
looking like her old self as for what
she's been up to these past few months
carrie has been hanging with her pro
hockey playing husband and their son she
says quote for me this healing process
is the time I've gotten to spend with
Mike and Isiah I've been calling it
forced relaxation sometimes I think
things happen in order to make us slow
down
[Music]
but it seems Kari is anxious to get back
to work she planning to go out on tour
soon and she'll be performing her new
single at the Academy of Country Music
Awards this Sunday on CBS in her letter
to her fans Kari revealed the title cry
pretty as a reference to when emotions
take over she says it really speaks to a
lot of things that have happened in the
past year that single is due out
tomorrow mana can't wait to carry the
ACMs on Sunday we're so rooting for her
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]